are you ready to rock
yep
i'm ready it's all ready you're here in
person
are we rolling oh god hey are you ready
hi rock
jake why don't you play your guitar when
you're here live
i believe in you too jake yeah i believe
in you you have the other one
so i haven't out of reach i have a
podcast topic i want to
throw out there
for you guys podcast topic yeah i don't
know if i'll wait for jake to play a
song on his guitar that's nice
this was the prop that i used when we
filmed
son of a dungeon is it really mm-hmm
yeah because of the string uh sling i
bought that guitar in chinatown i just
watched the part number on the window i
was like play me a song i was like no
no
episode three is a lot of fun episode
three is great when we were shooting and
it was like this is a full uh
roleplay episode i'm like it's either
gonna be a lot of work
[Music]
it's crazy one in the other
oh yeah led zeppelin smoke
oh dude i love the beatles
dang it guys
welcome back to the corridor digital
podcast i'm here in person um but i've
got good news for all of you wait you
being improtons are there's not good
news i've got even better news for all
of you troutons out there i uh
purchased a shore sm7b microphone
all right arrived at my house today
and i'm gonna have this bad boy set up
by next week so my audio quality is
gonna sound
like how you hear it here well it didn't
sound that bad in the last episode
yeah i got an audio box i got the cloud
lifter i got the whole setup so it's and
i even got a desk arm that i can screw
into my desk and then it comes up and
over my monitor
so i can go for the low profile so i can
move it around and no the low profile
ones i mean we had those on the table
when we used them
they now have rather than arms that go
up yeah you can find arms that go down
and they can just sit like hover right
above your desk
uh well i'll see what this one does you
know it's it was recommended b h photo
had it recommended with the package so
dude i love this and they gave me a
discount by buying that one you know
they do like little b h does little this
isn't a promo for b h i just like them
when you buy stuff on there they'll
often give you like suggestions for like
what to package it with oh yeah yeah
and uh usually they'll give you
discounts uh you know maybe they have
more stock of one thing or the other but
yeah it's great i got a whole setup
coming in
yeah it's going to be
muy bellioso i don't know if that's the
right word but i i don't speak russian
so son of a dungeon episode 3 just
dropped on the website today that's
right
guys it's heating up in the world
such a good night
i have something to admit okay
oh the chicken i
oh my god are we going to talk about the
chicken no no no um i mean i'm down to
you i just let it funny characters
i'll get to that because i've actually
only watched episode one so far
and you just randomly
go to three i didn't watch three either
i just skipped through three a little
bit today when it went live
so the reason why i haven't watched it
yet is because one jenna and i want to
watch it together and
you want to binge watch it i can't cast
it to my chromecast no
scott
dude so i that's how we watch stuff we
we we watch it on our tv and you don't
have apple tv 100
chromecast
you can't airplay from an iphone to it
out to another
that's never been a problem for all the
video players out there there's a little
button that goes cast to device
except for i'd fix that i would fix that
as you guys can you know what i'm glad
you're working on this i'm glad i'm glad
you brought this up bren because um
i have i'd like to just say how gracious
the audience has been for putting up
with some of the jank on the platform i
know that there's jank
and
we have
a to-do list a mile long
and we're bringing on another uh
developer uh well they're going through
testing right now and then if she starts
it'll be two weeks from now and then
we're bringing on the iphone guy full
time
um so
we know we got a giddy up um because
there's stuff like that and there's a
whole bunch of new subscribers and you
know so far it's been still very
positive but like legitimate i just want
to say i recognize the legitimate
issues with it chromecast is one of them
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
it's been very frustrating for me um
there's
but we're working through it and we're
gonna get through it thanks
just mind you this entire platform has
been built by scott
and two other people
on the ios and android side and now he
has a tester
customer service and a girl named olive
oh you know what i haven't actually
tried four people
four people congrats on expanding the
team for the website i remember when it
was just uh jake losing his mind in the
back corner yeah yeah well the first
before scott came along and said what
in this very polite english accent why
don't you guys have a website or a
video website and i was like that's the
worst english accent and i was like
well because we can't we can't like
who's gonna do it he's like i'll do it
and that's how it started so
like i scott's great yeah um
it's a testament to what they've done so
far and i can't wait to see with the
additional like
influx of
energy and resources and content like
where it's going to be in a year from
now i mean i am excited about the
website overall i am i think all the
content on there is on average i am
excited about it
as an average baseline i am approval
i am approval yes anyway i i love the
stuff on there i just literally i'm not
even kidding
not being able to cast it to my tv has
been a big reason why i haven't watched
more stuff on the website
you have a laptop don't you
i do have a laptop
laptop this is not a chromecast oh
or roku for that matter this is this i
have had people chromecast
the chromecast issue is like quickly
raised we're gonna redo green light and
and like redesign it a little bit
because there's a lot of functionality
that could be done better now the new
projects aren't coming out until winter
so the chromecast thing is like quick
it's like going
to the top of the to-do list because
yeah it's been a couple days now where
it's been just kind of now
what i have not tried yet is actually
logging into the corridor websites in a
browser like say chrome on my phone and
then trying to cast from that video
player rather than from the app i
haven't tried that either
well now i'm curious that smells like
another bug ready to pop out and say hey
but i gotta say honestly like i was so
blown away by episode one of son of a
dungeon like i had been holding off i'd
seen you guys working on it in my
peripheral vision for the last half year
and just like i've seen a lot of bits
here and there obviously i was part of
the game so i'm aware of the content
overall uh but it's like you know on
average it was about four hours of
filming
to one hour of final polished video
there's a lot of stuff that you got
trimmed down to just like the best parts
the streamlined stuff the stuff that
people actually care about and something
like that is what's there i mean it was
uh
it was so good so well refined chris
perkins lead designer of wizards of
coast when critiquing uh
dungeons and dragons 3.5
was
uh after playing a game of
three hours he goes wow that's like
condensed 30 minutes of fun
[Laughter]
and they've been just like trying to
make the game better to get more of that
ratio
yeah
well also yeah so many rules a lot of
there was a lot of uh us being we were
very
cautious i would say in the game overall
because
you never know what sam's going to do
in the beginning you guys were so
[ __ ] cautious you're like is he going
to kill us in right away in the first
round to be fair guys there's like eight
there's like eight
okay let's let's also not forget the
very first thing that i did in the
entire game which didn't make it into
the final episode was i sent chippy on a
mission down into a hole chippy is my
little chipmunk sitting on my shoulder
the whole time for the listeners i've
seen the first episode this is literally
when you walk into the cave and go to
the door before that happens there's a
brief detour runs like a hole what's in
it well no like we're in the cable we're
trying to get in the door is locked and
i'm like wanting to knock on it and
everyone's like no don't do that and
then before i actually like
did that
we found a hole and i was like oh chippy
go down to the hole and check it out i'm
like hi
and right off the bat
a monster comes out and tries to attack
chippy yeah and chippy's got like what
three or four health points like any
attack that lance was going to kill him
instantly
i fought for the scene because i thought
the idea of being like
ren's gonna learn a lesson in this scene
and we have an emotional stakes with the
chipmunk
there's like a lot of feelings there
but then the counter argument is is the
first
role initiative for this entire show
ren throwing a chipmunk into all that
also
but then but then uh the monster misses
and i'm able to bring chippy back now i
don't know how much of that was sam
going i can't have a death be the
literal first thing of this entire
campaign maybe he ruled rolled high and
was like it missed i don't know i'll
never know all i know is that that
scared the hell out of me and i never
once for the entire rest of the campaign
chippy was like
chippy yeah one of the one of the first
not the first no one of the most recent
campaigns i did with sam before we
played son of a dungeon
i ended up in some
rat infested like
hole inside of a house
pretty much right away
and so i was very cautious because
i didn't want that to happen again
that's fair
i mean the other thing too is you know
we're playing a game that needs to be
fun to watch and there's a few things
that that requires one is we can't just
blow all our spells right away yeah and
then have nothing for like the climactic
set pieces that sam has planned oh my
god dude or something
or you guys
ex like use up all your spells and then
you gotta be creative yeah well there's
also there's no rest periods because we
are playing a game and it does have
rules like true our characters can't
there's not a point at which we can rest
for this entire you know at least we
couldn't rest for the first two episodes
of this thing yeah and like remember
there's we
spoilers you haven't seen episode two
whatever there's a there's an actual
mind flayer that appears
in then we haven't rested yet after the
whole beginning bit with finding the
skeletons and falling down the hole and
all that kind of stuff
and fighting uh
ventilias as well
like if we had to take on that mind
flare like that could have killed us
right then and there and you know who
knows what sam would have had to do to
weasel out of that but like so that we
didn't die i don't know if he would have
but like i don't know i don't i don't
feel like sam
based off the conversation sam and i had
between
uh episodes
i was always making sure sam
wasn't putting
what's called plot armor on you guys
yeah no i remember uh yeah um
there were moments where
like
the risk is real yeah there are times
where he's like not sure if it's going
to be deadly or not and i would just
always
push him over the edge like just make it
deadly
they have a druid they'll be fine
yeah i mean our job as players is to
ideally never put him in that position
where he has to start fussing the
numbers to keep us alive because the
moment the moment he lies about or any
dungeon first thing i did
again allegedly who knows the the moment
a dm has to like lie about the dice roll
like the game is no longer fun right
because now nothing matters yeah yeah
you can't break the dice rule which
means i'll be tyrion lannister that's
why some dungeon masters roll all their
roles in front of the players
yeah and i'm like that's so awesome
yeah i don't know it's good to have the
the decision to you know make your own
calls in the story i agree i agree
yeah it's like every now and then i
think it is better for uh for sam to be
able to like make that executive
decision of like you know what it would
be better if this lands or doesn't land
or whatever but you can't do it too much
exactly like you just said it's like
if he actually just does that all the
time then nothing matters right but
looking back at the campaign i can't
think of any situations that we could
have approached really
like any better than we did like
everything executed i think about as
cleverly and as
good as possible what are you guys
laughing at i'm liking
i'm pretty uh intimately aware of what
happens
yeah oh wait there's some oh there's
some goof parts of course but yeah going
back to what i was saying earlier though
i had specifically avoided seeing any of
the rough cuts in the months leading up
to this i wanted to see like the final
thing as it was intended to be seen and
i have to say i was incredibly impressed
like just the polish on everything even
jenna was like that felt like tv that
felt like an actual episode of a high
production value tv show
thank you like it was fun and i'm
looking forward to watching episode two
as soon as i can cast it to my tv
let me know i'll get back to you in a
couple weeks on that i think there are
like apps where i can load like a video
player yeah called url into it there are
yeah that's right you have to use
intermediary apps uh to make it function
on some platforms yeah i don't need to
get into the details of it but
yeah
yeah the going into it was like
one of the major goals
was like
people who have
and have not played or watched d
should be able to enjoy it
and then
the photography at the table should be
as good if not better than any of the cg
work that's going to come later
yeah and then rule three is
uh i don't want to be
the big deviation from the node d d
shows i don't want to be filming a bunch
of filmmakers because a big part in the
node one is you guys would often pause
to kind of move the gopro and you get a
sense of like oh they're making it right
there on the spot
and where i like the idea of like just
stepping back the cameras are just
filming
normal people play d and d
gosh dang filmmakers can't trust them
can't trust them yeah they're going to
move those cameras all over it's going
to be chaos you're not going to have the
same angle
that's it
so when is season 2 coming out
yeah great question with that green with
that chromecast fix and that green light
page upgrade you think season two is
gonna be there oh yeah yeah yeah i think
it's i mean we're only three episodes in
and there's been like some tremendous
positive feedback both in terms of like
comments and engagement and in actual
subscriptions coming in
so it's obvious that people like it and
they've they've come to the site for the
show
um so we just now we need to do our job
and hold the bar into the bargain and
keep it up
um you know and given all the
advancements that
now we're gonna be able to make with
season two um we've got the magic box
which i keep the magic box that's the
virtual production box
um we've got a sort of an editing
workflow workflow in place and i know
exactly how to refine it to potentially
cut post production time down to up to
half
up to guaranteed up to 100
um so yeah i think if we film early next
year then we should hopefully get the
season out by june summer yeah and then
do two two seasons next year oh wow yeah
okay geez
we just need another editor
right
yeah i mean uh for me the biggest not
it's not a letdown but the whole promise
of virtual production is is that we have
like this camera that we can move and
the entire cg set moves with the camera
right you know it's a track camera and
we had all that working but there was so
much like so many issues surrounding the
technical side of that like there's a
speed limit we had to put it on a jib
and all that stuff like what i'm really
what i was really hoping for when we
first started talking about this which
hopefully
uh with the magic box we'll be able to
do in season two but is like i'm
confident with the magic box better
tracking right yeah it's that's what it
comes down to is better tracking
if we if if we can have a situation
where we can literally have a handheld
camera and be looking at someone like a
close-up down at the ground back up to
them and like looking around like that'd
be ideal that's the sort of thing that
no one can do with traditional
filmmaking on a green screen because
there's nothing to track correct yeah
that's that's what i find so awesome
about the virtual production with a
green screen is that okay we can't
afford to a 100 million dollar led
screen to put in a giant studio to make
uh
right mandolins mandolins to make
mandolins well some of the some of the
weird stuff that we sam and i noticed
was like we were like oh the scaling's
off like no the the scaling from the
mini set from dwarven forge is just
slightly
not realistic it's kind of cartoonish so
the fence is the size of the door
yeah when it's not supposed to so when
we look at the the footage it's like why
is the fence so big it's because it's
cartoonish yeah because it's so tiny
because there has to be like oversized
at that small scale yeah for the detail
to make sense yep and i'm sure they do
things like oh we'll just make the fence
the same size as the same height as the
like house walls because
then we can use the same mold for all of
it and it's more efficient for and
packaging and yeah
and all that yeah yeah
so if you guys could just make uh more
appropriately sized ones just for us
which is a little bit harder
but i mean regardless i think it's a
really cool and novel idea that we are
literally bringing the actual game
pieces and the game board to life yeah
that's gonna continue to improve as the
other seasons come along here yeah um
should be more uh shots
you know
presuming that we can get all the things
that need to work functioning i just
look forward to shooting some other
projects too using virtual production
yeah we really do get it so the tracking
is truly locked in like maybe i can
finally shoot that portal short that i
wrote a while back
i still want to shoot my moon video my
moon video if we get the tracking
working
and it it looks good
we're doing the moon i mean it already
looks good it just has to look great are
we on the moon are you on the moon i'd
be on the moon in the video
entire video i'm on the moon and it just
cuts
a lander landing on the moon me hopping
out of it and like taking off my helmet
and taking a big breath of air just like
and then like winking at the
vacuum just a camera locked off shot we
never needed the production and yeah
right but it just says like a way to
like all right let's get rid of all this
what happened
if you took off your mask on the moon
like would you just suffocate it's a
vacuum
yes
yeah is there an app there's a little
bit of an atmosphere no there's no
atmosphere i mean okay
asterisk there's like
tiny atmospheres on the moon but it's
like so insignificantly small that it
doesn't count okay um i mean but yeah
now you're talking about like what
happens when you're subjected to
instantaneous vacuum pressure yeah uh
yeah essentially your eyes would pop out
all your blood would instantly boil
uh
and you would eventually just kind of
suffocate you wouldn't die of being too
cold your blood would boil yeah isn't
there
kind of it's like you could survive for
like a couple minutes in vacuum all your
blood vessels would start bursting
everywhere uh but you could survive the
trick is to exhale all of the air out of
your lungs
right before you're subjected to it
yes that one
and jake when you said your blood will
boil that's what happens when you get
the bends
it's just
gas bubbles you know forming in your
blood oh so when you come up from the
ocean too fast yeah i hear it's
incredibly painful i would imagine your
blood is boiling
[Laughter]
so it's not boiling because it's hot
it's boiling because there's air bubbles
in it well it's boiling because the
pressure's so low so in physics there's
this thing called boyle's law where it's
the relationship between pressure
temperature and volume okay and so if
you lock off one of those
of the three the other two are like
what do you there's a
relationship between them
yeah their ratio
uh and so
in in your blood for instance if you
were to drop the pressure and you can do
this with water too if you drop the
pressure the boiling point temperature
drops as well okay yeah i've done that
experiment yeah and so yeah that
experiment you can do is called the
triple point of water we can literally
have boiling water
and ice in the same jar and of course
water vapor because you drop the
temperature and the pressure low enough
that it all just exists at the same
point called the triple point love it
yeah and so that can happen with any
liquid
like your blood
or your knuckles
nah what you're doing there is you're
literally boiling the synovial fluid in
your knuckles
because you're you're applying enough
pressure to increase the volume without
changing so the temperature stays solid
but you increase the volume which by
extension decreases the pressure causing
all the air bubbles in your synovial
fluid
instantaneously boil and collapse and
that collapse is what you hear as a
popped knuckle it is not bad for you oh
god
i'm good it's about people popping their
joints that i don't like
uh jenna loves watching chiropractic
videos at night ten years off running
dude the other day i fell asleep
watching that man yeah the other day i
fell asleep watching an hour long video
of a dude mowing somebody's lawn
and he's just talking about like
his business practice about starting up
a business as
uh taking care of people's lawns and
he's just going super professional in
this whole lawn this entire time he's
doing it for free because he drove by
and was like i should fix that
and he's just like going to town on this
sounds like you've got some competition
for the nicest guy i was just like i
know
and i was just like god this is so good
and then i watched the next video and he
was just power washing somebody say
power washing videos
washing the the driveway i was like oh
my god again for free
running a great business plan
i bought a lawnmower
recently you should you own lawn yeah
but it's it's it's like a you know it's
a texas lawn so it's not like exactly a
lawn it's it's not a minnesota there's
grass
right scrub but it's yeah and there's so
much dust when i mow
nico you're so relaxed right now i gotta
put my feet up to be comfortable
just who i am i agree putting my feet up
now now you're not only faced away from
us you're on your phone i'm listening
what are you doing it's a podcast i have
i've have this site checking out the ios
app i'm checking out the other camera
did you find any glitches
yeah it's called something don't touch
that that's a glitch
hey i have a thought experience for you
guys oh god i have a question for you
guys but you first
no you first carmichael all right did
you guys did you guys know that um
blade runner and alien are supposedly in
the same universe
on the same timeline
that's a that's a segway
yeah because they have replicants and
stuff don't they yeah also uh when
making blade runner ridley scott was
like i want los angeles to look like a
place where the nostromo crew would go
um
and then in aliens
too
uh
dallas who's the captain of the nostromo
when his like id card comes up on the
screen he says it says prior to working
at the nostrom uh on the nostromo he was
an employee at the tyrell corporation
huh nice little callback there you have
it folks we've done it we've solved it
you don't need to know anymore it's
great it's really cool it's done that
was that was such a carmichael moment
right there that was so i offered to go
second
it's good to have you back in the studio
man
by the way yeah carmichael's been in the
studio all the time lately finishing up
releasing yeah a freaking marathon
this marathon sprint what are you gonna
do after this is done long nap you can
take a vacation the long nap i'm going
to do a long nap and then go do this as
a hobby on my own time again
yes
sharpen those skills just constantly
playing tabletop games
so satisfying
and then record it and edit it just for
fun
tt rpg
we should get a shirt that says and it's
just tt rpg and it's just and the g just
keeps going he just keeps going yeah
yeah what i'm curious about this thought
experiment though yeah okay back on
track
so
i was thinking about you know the watch
time of our videos
and
you know like they say like i don't do
this at home kids because you'll hurt
yourself and it's like well how many how
do people watch my videos went out and
tried to do something they saw my videos
and hurt themselves all right everyone
everyone adrian adrian so
i mean i did so i took that a little
further
i was thinking about well
how
much how much human energy have we
absorbed with our videos how many how
many human lives worth of human energy
have we absorbed with our videos what
does that even mean like what does that
mean
human lives of energy weaving
human souls how many human souls just
chord or creatures
to the bottom of the math you're trying
to sound like you're saying like it
takes take the total watch time divided
by the total average
life and span yeah yeah okay so
so how many people is it what is the
lifespan currently at is it 70 or 80
years in minutes
i can i have my calculator ready to go
okay that's 42 million minutes we're
doing minutes hours
uh what is our total watch time and
divide that by 42 million so this is
this is assuming an 80 year old person
was
every second of their life
was vibrant and aware i mean if you
divide it by half you're pretty much
cutting out sleep and some work and some
eating yeah but let's go you know what
let's go with the whole hog right a true
human soul no no true souls yeah yep
would you diminish it anyway by half
because they wouldn't have time to eat
carmichael quit trying to diminish my
human souls okay listen it's a unit it's
seven hundred thousand eight hundred
dollars for an eighty seven hundred
thousand eight hundred so let's call it
a seven hundred thousand e okay wait
okay seven hundred thousand he said
forty two million 000 000 so 42 million
divided by 700 000. no no no that's
hours and minutes so
700 000 is one human soul
all right it's one it's one human's life
worth of energy
700 000 hours is the same as 42 million
minutes sure it is
vfx artist reveals true scale of attack
and titan
has consumed
one human soul
and a little bit of another human soul
it's it's got 800 000 hours
so ren has killed one human being with
that video
they picked one human being off the
planet and went
all your time and all you will do
nothing
except for watching this video
i mean it's a great video and it's a
great show wait light uh
real life lightsaber
the world's largest like hours and years
that's a 90 91 year old person
[Laughter]
91 years reyna's absorbed a 91 year old
person yeah that's my grandpa's age how
does that make you feel
that's that's cool do you feel it's cool
i mean no it's that's weird to think
about but i think it's also just like
you know because that that video has
what 10 million views this time video
and
you know it's a 10 minute video thank
you i think it's like 15 million now
it's oh my god jesus wait that might
have just been for the last 28 days
i'm consuming lifetime go live time all
right hold on i gotta go back i gotta go
back
all right i got lifetime world's longest
lightsabers pulled up right here
christian's got 4.8 million
yeah 4.8 million watch time hours
so
that's like seven people that we've
killed that video
[Music]
is there are you getting at a moral
obligation that arises from this sort of
experiment or i mean
i don't know is there a moral obligation
i mean i feel like maybe a little bit
i mean i think there's certainly a
little the ratio seems pretty low right
now
ratio like well like lightsaber videos
only killed like seven people that's not
really a problem
one video if that one yeah if that video
was doing like 20 people
that's a problem
isn't it 20 is 20
20 is a problem seven's double baker's
dozen okay got it well that's 24.
okay so that's 26. the second titan
video is lifetime eight hundred thousand
hours okay okay so that's one person not
a problem
ren just took one more thing off the
planet castle into the sun when you
release that video what does that mean
to you ren how do you think they turned
into a titan and stayed that way the
titans it does not feel about it it's
like
i don't know i i feel like you guys are
probably similar in the sense that you
know we've been doing this for long
enough that
considering the type of like views and
watch time on something is is i don't
know it's i'm a little numb to it
it's it's weird to consider
it's how we maintain our youth is by
absorbing human energy
here's a return question to your
question let's go lifetime on corridor
crew rather than in a second asking the
hours watched
as a viewer
what about the hours spent making
have we hit lifetimes no
because we're all like we're volunteers
early collectively
collectively collectively okay let me
put in this 12 people spend x hours on
one project
i think it you know that still is going
to come out to like maybe a few hundred
hours at night are you ready
yeah that's like wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
jake's gonna hit us with the lifetime of
the channel i'm gonna divide that by
seven hundred thousand one channel on
all channels just corridor crew okay
lifetime hours court or crew
122 million six hundred thousand i'm so
proud 122 million six hundred thousand
[Music]
so
oh my proud okay
the corner crew has killed 175 people
quarter crew took 175 human souls worth
of life energy off of this planet and
absorbed it into its frame
68 100 000.
thought so dang a lot more views on the
quarter channel but a lot less watch
time because there's shorter videos so
if you took 175 people in the moment
that came out of the womb you sat down
in front of a tv and they was playing
quarter crew and played until they were
80 and they passed away dude that's
literally what the they do in the matrix
that's how much time
our videos have been watched we've just
we've just leased out
from the matrix
three hundred thousand hours uh 18
channels not it hasn't been claimed at
30. not living up to its name yet
uh all right corridor cast let's see
uh
you know you know
i guess you know it's not he didn't kill
the person somebody took their time to
watch the video but theoretically waste
or spent during the time i mean as a
human being your experiences didn't
shape you so you know the next step they
took after they finished watching the
video ideally we enriched them in some
quarter casts
a half million hours
really yeah oh wow that's a couple
people right there
that is a couple exactly
yeah so i mean in reality and to get
haters
hopefully life has been enriched in some
way from the content hopefully it's
brought them some entertainment some joy
some hope maybe
i sure hope so
yeah hopefully the time after the video
was watched led to a return on the time
watch well jordan peterson has this
interesting thing on uh like that which
is this idea that
the more people there are
the more
possibility exists for somebody to be
like a genius above and beyond uh
you know the average person so therefore
the
more people you have the more
likely it is that you'll be able to
solve some of humanity's greatest
problems
because there's more people which is
counter-intuitive to think about that
but yeah more people is definitely more
people are the best
people are the
you best
testing people are the people are the
inventors
yeah yeah yeah the more people you have
working on a problem
the quicker it gets solved generally
speaking obviously nuance
there's a lot of nuance to that yeah
but yeah i think i think it's did we
take people away from problem solving or
did we
did we like give them a more solid
foundation upon which to solve problems
we're just gonna gloss over what you
just said
who said what
who said what okay first to start off
with with uh like your subjects a lot of
people yeah carmen was like test
subjects yeah you chuckles and you're
like sorry my enter german's coming out
oh my god
jesus
and everyone just like
moved on jake and i were busy talking
about the holidays we were talking about
human beings nature of humanity yeah
human beings are a positive force
for humanity was i not part of that
conversation yeah yeah renowned for
their productivity germans are modern
healthcare wouldn't be what it is
without germans there you go
nor would many places in america or
would uh german immigrants
yeah yep all right
all right but like thinking about
like
views and stuff like that it's it's
when we get to those kind of high
numbers i don't know it it like maxes
out any sort of sensor that i have like
it's just being [ __ ] but where i find a
lot of value is when i get messages from
people saying that they saw my videos in
their classroom yeah you know like that
sort of thing i'm like wow
come on do your work
but this guy already did it
i think it's super cool yeah it's the
best i got an email from a dude who uh
told me that he shared it with his
thermodynamics professor at purdue which
one uh what which video oh the uh
hey look i know thermodynamics and all
that but you got to see this
we haven't talked about the world video
at all yet on the podcast uh since it
came out but uh so
so with that video he shared with this
thermodynamics professor and his
professor said it was one of the best
researched
of
projects on the topic he'd ever seen and
now he's having that's because he's
dealing with college kids all the time
he's having their entire
uh class do all of their senior projects
on concepts introduced in my video oh
really [ __ ] awesome like like reverse
engineering some of the math i did to
get to some of those things kind of like
taking some other ideas and kind of
extrapolating there like energy costs
environmental costs that's what it feels
like stuff like that this is what it
feels like to be at vsauce
i don't know we're not there i mean we
can go across the street and be there
are they still over there i mean i'm not
exactly sure they've got the place but i
don't know if they are
like full-time still there did jake come
back from new york or do you know no
he's been back he's been back uh they've
been i mean he just finished his whole
season two of
uh the the movies the can you survive
the movies yeah and
so i don't think he was working out of
the studio for that okay
yeah post-production was i believe
was it yeah
that's the central hub yeah but i know
uh eric wasn't working
oh studio there and he was a primary
artist on that show
i don't know i i have honestly i haven't
really talked to those guys that's
stupid
it's super cool that like
wren is the subject of a class subject
not me just the the influence i mean
sure uh i'm just trying to say that like
in terms of
impact and stuff like that when i see
one of my videos being shown in a
classroom at a school that's when i
realized that i've actually done
something good yeah my my content will
never do that
99 schools the scientists they are you
know your story you've influenced souls
in a positive direction right hell yeah
it's good that you're doing that to make
up for all the human souls you've
observed
it's good that you're doing that to make
up for the world's longest lightsaber
[Laughter]
watchtime in views on a video on the
scale of son of a dungeon
like
five views can still be a single person
because they only made it so far and
they're like so you you want to come
back to this do you want to see how many
human souls who absorb with some of the
dungeons so far oh no you can see that
just the the youtube version the youtube
version
because that one's going to be
interesting because it's an hour long
video
i don't know how many views it has
obviously most people probably didn't
watch these
michael you're gonna be disappointed
i know i've i've looked
yeah it's like
a 20 year old be a-ok watching that
video
they'd be they'd be finished they'd be
off to college ready to live the rest of
their life i mean we've already consumed
a 20 year old in the last week less less
so we can seem like we've already
consumed a teenager
the teenager
is such a weirdo
we've given a child their entire
upbringing to 18 and then set them off
into the world but they've watched only
the episode one and son of a [ __ ] all
that they know
[Music]
bob had an influence on that that's all
they know
one person in the world is walking
around out there where all they know is
son of a dungeon
i really like us abstracting the view
and watch time to just one person
so only one person has watched for this
many hours
the same video on on repeat just over
and over and over again like like being
a guy like in the tubes in wall-e
but we would have to wait if that were
the case we'd have to wait 18 years for
that to happen
not unless they have that many monitors
unless they have a bunch of accounts
yeah they're like an indian click farm
oh my goodness where is any of this
analogy going right now i'm so confused
it wasn't going anywhere it was just oh
yeah it was a thought thought experiment
speaking of other thought experiments
nico challenged me to
an experiment uh earlier today oh we can
talk about this can't we yes we can talk
about it so there is a conclusion but it
yeah it's fine we can talk about it we
don't have a secret video we did we did
this
video and i couldn't tell anybody about
it because it required it to be secret
however obviously i can tell nick about
it since he's gonna be the one making it
and
jake seemed like the perfect person to
make the video so we were the three
people that knew about this idea no one
else in the office knew about it and
today jake filmed it that's right so the
idea was nico
in a fit of rage
came to me and said jake there's no way
that batman can just disappear in the
middle of a conversation
like he does in so many different
iterations of the batman universe he's
talking with harvey dent he's talking
with commissioner gordon he disappears
right where does he go nobody knows it's
just assumed that because he's batman he
disappears well he's not some
interdimensional being he can't just
disappear he's a human
right so oh [ __ ] he had to have gone
somewhere
so he either hid
or he
left
right he turned into a bat he just he
can't turn his ability turned into a hat
maybe he turned his invisibility cloak
in fact if he did turn and if he could
turn into a bat he'd probably be
terrified he'd be a vampire he'd be a
vampire man vampire man he'd just be a
vampire
yeah i mean he kind of is a vampire that
man's just a poser vampire he's like
he's like a modern actually dude he is
kind of like a modern vampire if he
could turn into a bat he would be a
vampire think about it he's a
billionaire he's got access to everybody
you know batman he's got
[Laughter]
so we were talking about batman
disappearing and how it's like it's not
realistic at all yes so i find it very
distracting yeah and no one would ever
react like they do in the movies right
okay so we did some actual tests to see
if that was indeed the case yeah and uh
well i mean
why don't you guys take us through what
happened
was i the first one no you were the
second or third okay
um i was way too caught up in the
distraction yeah um and when i realized
you had disappeared yeah i was like jake
disappeared that's weird i went back to
my distraction
so what you didn't do
is go and look for me being like hey
where did he go he has to be around here
somewhere i mean i kind of did and i
looked around and i didn't see you and i
was like that's so weird jake was here a
moment ago now he's not
i thought maybe you'd gone downstairs i
honestly didn't really worry about it
i was like i guess he does
exactly and that's what they say in
batman and i was in a similar boat
well for me it was i go to it and i the
first thing i did was i picked up the
distraction and i
commented about the cover of the
distraction to jake yeah to be kind of
like a [ __ ] about it
and he's gone yeah and i was like well
there was no sound or cue that he left
the area and
there was a visual cue to like oh things
are different than what i normally
remember from this area
he's probably hiding
and then i go back to the distraction
all the way and i'm like oh interesting
and i just like went through it as if
there's like there's more to this
experiment and i just stood there for
like almost like half a minute like yeah
i'm done with this [ __ ] i pretty much
did the exact same thing i was i thought
i didn't realize jake disappearing was
the bit
so i was just like really going in like
what's going on i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna
get shocked or or like surprised by
someone a bell goes off what was your
setup what was your setup well it was
just a lot of smoke and mirrors so the
first thing uh was we called freddy
and
because freddy is a member of the magic
castle if i'm not mistaken and he's an
official magician okay and so you know i
was like freddie we gotta fool some
people you know what what is the idea
like what is the philosophy here like
what what are the techniques that i need
to employ and he strongly encouraged me
to use like
psychological like uh
gesturing you know like non-verbal so
like you know you you came into the room
we had a we had a very basic distraction
which was just some things in an
envelope which had nothing to do with
what we were trying to accomplish it was
just there simply as a red herring and
so
everyone's on edge you take them into
this environment it's unfamiliar they
don't know what's going on they're
they're you know
predator sensors are on a high alert
yeah so then as soon as you as soon as
you're like okay that's the thing and
then
you yourself are like yeah there it is
you know and you you relax
then they relax and it's like okay you
just want me to open this and you're
like yeah just open it tell me what you
think and then and then that's when you
strike
[Laughter]
what helped was i don't know if you did
to everyone else but you had to let up
a leading story yeah the before
yeah i did that with everybody okay
tell us more so like
i mean
like
how did you do this you're in the lower
third of the frame
how did you just
gonna disappear out of the frame
so uh so the first thing i said was
i had a kind of an elaborate backstory
actually we had to tone it down as time
went by because people were too focused
on the story yeah the original story was
okay last time i was in town i hid an
envelope upstairs
uh and it's sort of out of place up
there because it's a costume room and
there's this random manila envelope up
there so i was wondering if anybody
would find it and no one did so if we
were going to film a video where if
somebody found it we were going to take
the video in one direction and we were
going to film another video if no one
found it well no one has found it so now
it's your turn to go up there and inside
of the envelope is a special piece of
information now it's going to seem
normal at first but i want you to tell
me what you think it means
and so
and that's all just a ploy right
and so then everybody was like okay this
is super weird and they pull it out and
it was just a it was just a to-go order
venue from like an italian place down
the street
of fake money oh yeah yeah some people
had the fake money we had to take the
money out because it was also getting
too distracting oh that explains you
didn't get the money no it's like second
to last
so uh so then as we sort of honed in on
it we tried a few different things at
first i had
we had this whole bin set up with all
the hats
upstairs and then i made a little like
area behind it yep and then i had the i
had that safari hat
and when they would and then i put them
i put the manila envelope underneath the
bin and then i duck i gaff taped it to
the table that it was on so a lot of
people saw it and they went to pull the
manila envelope out but then it didn't
come out right away so then immediately
they forgot which is unusual yeah yeah
immediately because
yeah you forget about where you're at
and you're like wait what is wrong with
this envelope so then you lift it up and
you're like what is taped down and when
they would go for that that's when i
would hide you know that i would take
the hat and put it on me and then i
would i would literally hide behind the
rest of the hats with just my hat
sticking out above it hiding behind the
bin
[Laughter]
the only person who actually came back
and found me was red
[Applause]
oh my gosh and then i had another
distraction that we started with because
i was too worried that it was gonna be
too hard
and i had a shoe i had a shoe and and
when i went to put the hat on and i was
i would also take the shoe and throw it
over the stairs so that there'd be the
sound of shoes going down the stairs oh
man
and that actually worked so well that we
had to take it out
because everybody thought that i had
went downstairs
[Laughter]
and then the camera was up there at
first and the camera was super
distracting so then we just used hidden
cameras and that way it was just me and
the other person up there and no no nick
camera because oftentimes when the
camera's on the lights on it's like well
i'm not going to turn to the other
person i'm going to turn to the camera
because the camera's documenting it so
then we took the camera out wow and then
after we did the upstairs we did the
final back back room hallway
because there's one scene in the dark
knight rises where he's in this hallway
with i think harvey dent or commissioner
gordon and he just disappears so we're
like okay let's do the hallway and then
we had this little bucket with an
overhead light and the envelope was on
the bucket and the
envelope was taped from the bottom
so then people would go up to the bucket
and then they'd go to pull the envelope
and it'd be stuck and then when they
realized that it was stuck that's when i
would at first i started sneaking into
the to the uh maintenance room and
hiding behind the door and i had this
blanket like it's a good spot drop down
solid spot yeah and and and i had no
shoes on so it was dead silent and i was
well that's why you weren't wearing
shoes
yeah because we were walking up there i
was like wow you're all in black
you got black pants yeah black shirt yep
black shoes are you wearing shirt shoes
i can't tell
and so then i was hiding behind there
but that was too easy again so then
there's that little like corner when you
walk into this i mean too easy like it's
too easy i hid and people didn't know
where i was
it was too easy to disappear
mid-conversation yeah
well and what i look so i'll get to the
conclusion
so then we then we're like let's push it
even further let's see how close to the
person i can be
well they're picking up the envelope and
hide at that exact moment so we put the
we put the bucket right there in the
back in the prop room
and then there's that little to the left
where all the suitcases are stacked up
you know when you walk into the prop
room and we cleared that out and i
draped a blanket from the pipe down and
so literally people were like from me to
you or actually even closer from like me
to carmichael and they would go to reach
for the envelope and as soon as they do
that i would just dip behind
me oh my god
and it worked
it worked
wow that's amazing really that's
actually really really interesting the
brain works so fast what was the
reaction
so eventually nick would like suss it
out he'd like you know and eventually
i'd come out and a couple people i
spooked but still out of all the people
in the back nobody knew
where i was and when i did come out they
were freaked out
like ren had the same thing he thought
he saw me but he wasn't quite sure and
he just kind of like casually like
lifted the eye the hat
and and then i popped out and i was like
you got batman
i uh yeah cause i i i looked over and i
was like i thought i saw your show i saw
your shoulder but i wasn't sure what i
was seeing because yeah
you choosing that black outfit worked
really well camouflage because it was a
camouflage in the shadow yeah yeah and
and the hat on top you had like that
weird hat on i'm like
what is
that i thought it was your mannequin at
first okay
jake and i was like oh why how did that
get up here and i grabbed the head i
pull it off and your head immediately
goes
i like jumped backwards and yelled and
when you weren't there anymore
uh i was like all right well i guess
this is a weird experiment so i go down
the stairs as i go down the stairs from
the costume room yeah nick is holding
cradling the camera and he just turns
like something caught his attention he
looks back this way i was like oh jake's
down there now
i don't know how he [ __ ] got down
there but that's really cool i get down
there you are nowhere inside like this
is too far for jake yeah so he's still
up there
there was only like after that that he
didn't realize
nick brought me back up and on the way
up it was your timing because i heard
or you're moving around
coming back up and i tried to hide to a
different area of the costume area you
picked
this
my brain skills i've walked in the room
instantly
different yeah there is now a in my
brain a black box with a hat on it
in front of the spot where i was just
standing
and it was like
literally metal gear solid question mark
yeah
and i had the lights and i was like
how'd that get there what is that is
that jake and i even glanced as i'm
moving up i'm like you could probably
see in the footage my eyes are like
tracking each spot where you could have
been as i'm re-entering the room yeah
and i even go up
trying to lead nick to like kind of kick
and bump the box yeah but it's and i was
like oh that's just a box that's not
jake
i hate you in a certain spot that that
my brain was like that's not jake
that's not a person i just kicked
and then you just
you got batman yeah
dude
so what i realized was and this will
come through in the video um but what i
realized was
quite obvious but still worth noting
people don't expect you to disappear in
the middle of a conversation
and so because people don't expect it
it's actually very easy to do
because they don't and they don't know
like you already have it set up so that
was another thing freddy said was like
set do your set first and then you have
to like lure them into an area where you
know exactly where the traffic is in the
controlled environment yeah into the
dungeon right so it's not like you can
just do it willy-nilly right yeah but
because we were in this controlled
environment where i knew exactly where
to hide it worked
um and that's why you know batman
doesn't he always isn't he always there
when people get there
maybe he's like setting up trap doors
and stuff i want to see next batman
movie like someone goes to pick up and
pick up an object and then
cut to revealing batman's gone as if
like batman planted that object or they
already do that in the dark knight rises
where he plants something he's got the
what's his girlfriend's name
batwoman no
the bat mormon does disappear on him
catwoman
is this cat a woman yeah she's catwoman
so she does disappear on him that's a
big lure so that's what that feels like
yeah right right there is one
is it rachel
is said her name she she's dead but yeah
yeah
um so her character she's dead
in the film she watched too many
corridor videos
oh my god
he throws down like some pictures
he's like what do these mean to you or
something i don't remember what he says
oh and she picks him back up and he's
gone yeah in the very first movie by the
train station yeah yeah
yeah
so what do you expect me to do with this
and he just hear his voice distant i
expect josh
and she turns it
[Laughter]
like
he's jumping under the bridge and just
like i love i love the implication that
when batman disappears like that he
doesn't actually leave he just hides and
waits for the person to leave and then
he can leave
and that's why we have to be there
that's why we cut to bruce wayne at
wayne manor just always sleeping in his
meetings because he's so exhausted from
hiding yeah i mean my quads hurt
after that because there were so many
times where i had to kneel and crouch
and squat and just perfectly try to be
still
we did this with everyone in the studio
so you got a good dozen of those yeah i
got it i got at least a dozen yeah
what's up
i am very curious now because
you issued this challenge to jake you
didn't believe that this would be a
normal thing
and now
now we're going to let the video
evidence speak for itself yeah yeah so
jake needs to show me this like final
compilation because
my
my assertion was that people would not
react like they do in the movies the
cartoons they would either just be like
what
or like
ignore it and just kind of keep doing
their thing
um which they do in the movies they're
like oh
i guess you're sure he does that for him
i mean yeah if there's no clear spot
where he went they probably like he only
went through that corner and they'd go
and they'd look
there he is well we're gonna have to
wait and see the video evidence
to see what the final result is because
if there's anyone in the studio that
could pull off the batman vanish though
i knew it was you jake
it's right man for the job
yeah i'm actually really excited to see
what the reactions are like
the whole video is just gonna be a
montage of people
cutting on people's faces going what
there you go
yeah i don't think i even shrugged i
looked up and you were gone and i kind
of like looked for all the places you
could have been and then i just went
back
just like the syphilis bot i don't even
think my head moved i was just like
i got natalie pretty good really yeah
because she
she was very skeptical and then uh she
went for the bucket the envelope but the
envelope we forgot to tape it down
so then she picked it up
and turned right away oh and then i was
like oh that was my exit
but we had we took out you know that
little figurine of dobby yeah that we
have we have that sitting on the bucket
so i was like oh before you open the
envelope make sure that you're holding
dobie it's very important and then she
turned to grab him and i slipped behind
the curtain
i'm looking forward to seeing this video
yeah
that's exciting
we're going to do uh we're going to
review the evidence on friday
maybe tomorrow cool sweet and make our
final conclusions that's so funny
so we got that going for us over here
how many uh souls do you think that will
eat up
you know i don't know
at least half a human
hopefully a half a human half a human
that'd be great all said and done half a
human
yeah
what what what moral obligations
results what how do we better people's
life with that video i wonder it's like
hmm
well they know what to look for now if
somebody disappears if anything you've
improved
the future batman movies true there you
have it true that's that's and that's
going to consume at least the comic
books that's probably going to consume a
lot more souls than corridor because all
the all the younglings who watch
corridor right now are going to be
future comic books artists for batman
okay yeah here we go
isn't edward cullen in the new batman
yep yeah yep i'm so excited glistening
batman
i almost called him edward scissors
hands edwards
i'm super excited for that movie though
when's that coming out
uh
question mark zero question question
mark
you know what you know what movie never
came out and i'm still frustrated
because it's not out
top gun too yeah when is that movie
coming out tonight too
i'm so excited for it why is this so far
just for the fact of how they filmed it
i'm so excited i mean yeah clint and i
were gonna go to the imax theater and
see it oh my god what a rush and then
and then it got
delayed you just watched it i wonder why
maybe it's because tom cruise doesn't
maybe he doesn't have 20 20 vision and
so they said look but
you can't be a fighter pilot no he's
colorblind cards for you he's colorblind
and he's like how about 2022 vision
they're like all right
they told him he's color blind so he
couldn't fly and he's like no
no and he went to the library of all
colors and memorized exactly what color
would be in his own vision there you go
and then he mapped it out and he went
flying and it was perfect there you go
he would work that hard
is the name is that how colorblind works
to tom cruise it does
i'm pretty sure that's not how it works
the gods of scientology did itself oh
okay okay well there you have it yeah
yeah
isn't the new mission impossible isn't
part of it in space yeah yeah i'm so
excited isn't it going to space didn't
they throw off a train
james bond now with that oh dude
fast and furious nine oh my god
so good i mean f9 f9 they go into
outdoors
they said
outer space
and they have to take out the satellite
before it finishes uploading the death
weapon that sounds dumb well
it's so dumb but great while inner
cutting to vin diesel in a perfect clean
white shirt sounds like a man driving a
like a snake truck as a drone jet is
coming to shoot a rocket at them and he
whips it and the truck just whips off
the cliff and he takes out the drone jet
with the tail end of the truck we could
pitch shift your voice down so you sound
like you're five years old and the
awards would be exactly the same thing a
five-year-old would say you know what it
sounds like
that plot sounds like if family guy was
making fun of hollywood that sounds like
the plot that they were
that's what
fast and furious has become yeah they
yeah one of the characters in it
goes we're immoral like uh i'm sorry
we're immortal
like i was just surrounded by ten guys
with aks and they shot at me and i have
bullet holes in my shirt but nothing hit
me
wow
they just call it out they just try to
start calling things out wow he's like i
can do this you can't do this you're
going to die
we're the heroes and he goes to do it
wow
that's an interesting embracing of what
it is and then he's at the very peak
when he's in outer space and
everything's about to fail he starts
questioning see i like i like bollywood
films because of that because there
there's already this suspension of
disbelief because they build in so like
like bahubali
like that
yeah those those franchises uh because
he's already it already has these um
mythological underpinnings sure his
character is already a mythological
figure
when it starts so immediately you're
like well he's like a demi-god so yeah
it's like watching hercules yeah and
that that to me makes it more
entertaining because it's it's not like
no this is a human
there's no way they could do this right
um so all the ridiculous stuff that he
does in that movie is so much better
because
you can believe it almost right in the
universe but also what comes into that
is like okay they're a demigod clearly
they can do this so the question is how
are they going to do it
and
what insane things is the antagonist
going to put in their way yeah
wendy was so i watched that movie with
my wife and she was so confused
because it's it immediately starts and
it's like he's a baby and they're
singing and dancing and then all of a
sudden he's trying to climb this
mythical mountain that has no top
effectively
mm-hmm and and and and then like his
wife appears to him in like the mist of
the waterfall and
he likes to be clear we're not talking
about fast and furious no to be clear
we're not talking about disney's
hercules
um but yeah after that she was
i was so into it i was like yes what's
gonna happen next what's this guy gonna
do
man i was going to watch
the suicide squad because it was up on
hbo max and i was really excited to
watch it
not on hbo yeah what the heck because i
forgot that hbo has this deal where
every movie is only up for a month and
at the end of that month the next
movie's up yeah and so i totally missed
it interesting gotta get in on that dog
yeah
yeah i watched that clint eastwood movie
cry macho
how was it um
it's a very like standard clint eastwood
movie in the sense of uh it's uh it has
those traditional cowboy plot points
where you mean samurai plot points yeah
basically i mean same thing
at the beginning of the movie
they start and there's this scene and
then he has this conversation with the
guy and then it immediately cuts to a
year later
i was very confused why they had the
first scene in the first place um
classic
yeah and then uh he goes down to mexico
to bring back this kid's son and you
know they encounter all this trouble on
the way
um
so it was all right it you can tell how
old clint eastwood is though for sure
he's 91 years old i'm still waiting for
the movie where clint eastwood like does
a time traveling movie
where he gets his son to play him his
younger self that would yeah because
they look like they look very that would
be perfect dude
there's no cg needed something uh i
forget his son's name is it scott scott
eastwood he was in uh
pacific rim two mm-hmm
and
before then jenna they made a second one
of those the first one bombed no the
first one did great this one did great
the second one yeah the second one
bombed this i mean the and first one did
all right and it was also great the
second one i think are we talking about
the same movie
yeah
charlie
yeah yeah
okay cause i thought that movie bombed
no no i don't know if it bombed per se
okay it made it i don't think it i don't
think it did great i think it actually
probably did worse than they were hoping
okay i still think that movie apparently
anyway but my point being yeah so he was
in that second movie and when i watched
it with with jenna he was in another
movie that we watched as well i forget
which one but up until that point the
only screen time either of us had ever
seen of scott eastwood was as the love
interest in the
taylor swift music video
uh uh dreams
uh
where are they going wilderness
why do you know this so well carmichael
alicia is a die-hard fan so i'm this is
probably my favorite music video i'm not
going to lie it's
something
t swift fan or scott eastwood fan
t-swift okay
it's because it was directed by joseph
khan who is responsible for the most
views on the internet
and
he made this music video and is so well
done it tells one of the best stories
i've ever seen in a music video every
single shot has so much intention behind
it the cinematography is amazing the
editing and pacing is great and the
music is like cool i mean it's a taylor
swift song
anyway he was in that movie in that in
that that music video thing and jenna
thought he was such a heartthrob and
then she heard him talk and she's like
never mind
he has like a high-pitched voice and it
like doesn't match his like clint
eastwood demeanor yeah
that's that was where this whole story
was going to you see i guess he needs to
smoke some more marble reds i guess
yeah
uh have you any of you guys have hulu
yes yes have you been watching uh
murder in the building no no
i only have hulu so i can watch sports
really
and i can't when you say that all i can
think about is the sports ball
i would love to talk to you about hulu
but
i'm reaching the end of my day here i
gotta go home dude i need some dinner
the end of my day was four hours ago
well you don't know about that dude
you're still
here nico's gonna sink right out of this
podcast if he goes any longer i got some
chicken thawing at home
good for you if you can sneak out of the
bottom of the frame i mean i can let me
take a look but you can only you can
only go out of the bottom of the frame
yeah you have to go to the bottom keep
going keep going keep going
you're out stay low don't don't get back
up be careful don't forget your phone
[Laughter]
watch it
all right all right he's gone ladies and
gentlemen where'd it go there you go
nigga's gone
he just batmanned us all right well hey
i think that's the end uh
episode 3
is up now on quarter digital if you want
to watch it um or if you want to wait
until episode 8 comes out and then get
your two-week free trial and then watch
all the episodes
listen if it's not worth 3.99 to you
after that then you know
i don't know what to tell you hey this
is not a spoiler but episode 7 and eight
are beasts yeah uh and i just spent
probably half a day yesterday
just working out
what happens in episode five
and sam thought i was so [ __ ] crazy
what
he thought it was so crazy for what i
did to episode five
and then like i was like no come on down
and experience what i'm experiencing i'm
editing with mario kart music and it
makes sense
and he goes you're crazy and then he
watches it without any music and he goes
oh my god you're right
there you have that
no spoiler so okay so
i think
if you want to wait until episode 8
drops so that you can get a two-week
free trial to watch all of it
i would prefer you do that than to not
watch this at all yeah well yes yeah
obviously we put too much time into it
yeah
but you know who made this show possible
all the people who didn't do that so if
you want to see another season
you know just saying yeah
yeah i think oh yeah so episode three's
out
so the comments about the orphan in the
previous podcast will now make sense if
you go watch episode three
[Music]
all right uh should we wrap this up yeah
yeah what kind of wrapping paper do we
have you guys have to sneak out a frame
too
[ __ ]
[Music]
i'm just hanging out right here waiting
yeah it's still here nigga's still here
hey guys this is foreign
oh man
[Music]
dude epis episode four is next week
and episode five is the week after that
three
two one